I'm going to talk about the benefits of
something called tadka okay what does it
stand for well it's a very very long
name for a very specific bile acid
and this type of bile acid has been
found to be present in Bears now they
used to kill a lot of bears just for
this bile because it was so valuable
um but now they made it synthetically
which seems to work pretty good and um
they don't have to kill the Bears
anymore which is a good thing
but this treatment using this very
specific bile acid has been used for
hundreds of years in Asia it's been used
by the American Indians for various
purposes
it's used for treating gallstones
because a gallstone is a lack of bile
and it's a super concentrated
cholesterol stone that can be dissolved
when you add more bile also this type of
bile acid is used for liver cirrhosis
because it inhibits fibrosis which is
scarring of the liver so anyway it's a
really great ingredient for a lot of
different things especially if you've
tried everything and nothing's worked
try this because it's very very
effective at a lot of different
conditions
um let's just talk about what it can do
it can help you thin your bile many
people have a situation where their bile
is too thick and they might not develop
a stone but they have a lot of pain in
the right lower quadrant of their
abdomen so they have a lot of congestion
bloating and that can create
pancreatitis it can create a whole bunch
of issues because the bile then backs up
into the liver and it's a detergent so
it's very very irritating to the liver
tissue and that can cause pain and shoot
up to your right shoulder blade and up
to the neck and create headaches create
a whole bunch of problems now also
realize that where the liver is located
on the right side when it gets backed up
it can put pressure in the heart it can
put pressure on your lungs so it can
affect breathing it can affect the heart
it can create palpitations and even
arrhythmias by having the liver being a
little bit too swollen and uh because
there's just not enough space in that
area so there's a lot of benefits to the
Heart by taking this Tut cut now some of
you are going to ask me what type of
brand should I buy whatever well I'm not
going to recommend a certain brand
that's up to you to do that research
because I can't get involved with trying
to figure out what the quality is and
regulate them because if I recommend a
certain product and then they change the
formula so you just have to do your own
research on that but I recommend the
dosage to start out if you have a major
problem take two on an empty stomach in
the morning and take two in the
afternoon an empty stomach but if you
take it with food it's going to help you
digest the food all right number two
there's been a lot of research in the
past in ongoing research on the eyes on
retinal degenerative disease on various
problems with the eye on improving
visual acuity
uh why because bile helps you break down
and absorb vitamin A and there's a lot
of other reasons why it helps the eye as
well number three it's been shown to
improve symptoms of Parkinson's disease
why because it's neural protective it
seems to help the neurons in your brain
it also has shown positive effects on
Alf that is a certain autoimmune disease
okay so if you have ALS you should be
taking cut cut number five it's shown
benefits of not just preventing a stroke
but also repairing the damage of stroke
because it's neural protective in your
brain all right number six it's it's
good for spasms number seven it can
reduce fevers number eight it can prove
your eyesight which I I mentioned
previously number nine it prevents
something called apoptosis which is
program cell death caused by a stressed
mitochondria so in other words tatka
helps to stabilize
the mitochondria and it prevents this
program cell death
very very powerful number 10 it has very
good anti-inflammatory effects
especially of the liver so if you have
any liver problem like cirrhosis
hepatitis or or a fatty liver this would
be a good thing to take number 11 it can
decrease fibrosis which is very cool
number 12 it protects the brain I
already mentioned that and it can
decrease plaquing of those beta amyloid
plaques in the brain very cool 13 it can
support insulin sensitivity so if you
have insulin resistance it can help with
that condition it can make insulin more
sensitive so for a diabetic it's really
good stuff number 14 it supports the gut
lining if you have leaky gut or there's
some permeability issues where there's
food that's getting into the pores of
your intestine this would be a good
thing to support that condition
especially if you have like inflammation
of the colon itself
and number 15 it helps protect the
kidney so as you can see it does a lot
of things and I just scratched the
surface so anyway I just wanted to bring
your awareness up of this great tool in
helping various conditions I've
mentioned it in other videos but I just
wanted to create a separate video just
on this one very cool bile acid
hey before you go real quick I have a
course entitled how to bulletproof your
immune system it's a free course I want
you to take it and here's why
here's you
you here is your environment
everyone is focused on this over here
avoiding your environment but what about
here what about strengthening your
immune system that's what's missing this
course will show you how to bulletproof
yourself and so you can tolerate and
resist your environment much better by
strengthening your own immune system I
put a link down in the description right
down below check it out and get signed
up today